Follow focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
A couple of months back I made a video
about whether English is really a
dramatic language or not and I made the
rather controversial statement that in a
sense English is a hybrid language
because so much of its vocabulary comes
from the romance languages and from
other languages.
That statement was controversial because
of the core of English is indeed
Germanic and it is actually possible to
speak English with mostly or entirely
dramatic words.
For example,
instead of saying literature,
which is a romance word,
you could say book craft or instead of
saying ancestor,
you could say for Ken,
it's not exactly easy to speak that way
all the time,
but it is possible.
There is actually a movement to create
and to promote a new form of English
like this that stripped of all of its
nondramatic influences so that English
would basically become the language of
would have been if it had not been
influenced by romance languages and by
Greek and others.
Some people refer to this strictly
dramatic form of English as English
because it's supposed to take English
back to it's Anglo Saxon roots.
English as a form of English linguistic
purism.
English seeks to achieve the Germanic
purity of English in a few different
ways.
First,
by choosing existing dramatic words
rather than the romance equivalence to
by reviving obsolete Germanic words.
Three,
by adopting words from old English or
other Germanic languages for by creating
new words based on old English or other
Germanic roots.
So take this simple sentence.
The man forgot his reign shade at home.
What do you think?
Rain shade means something that provides
shade from the rain.
If you guessed umbrella.
That's right.
Rain shade is a new word created from
rain and shade,
and it's based on the word sunshade.
Umbrella is a lone word from Italian
umbrella.
All of the other words in this sentence,
our regular English words of Germanic
origin.
And you probably noticed that the words
are not changed into old English.
They're all in modern English just
without the nondramatic elements.
Another example,
I unlocked the man since he's very
isn't.
Now here's the original sentence I wrote
in standard English.
I respect the man because he's very
industrious on look comes from old
English on lake to observe or regard,
but it seems the cents has been extended
to me in regard positively or respect.
Now,
why did I change the word because.
Well,
because the cause part of because is of
romance origin since it's just a
dramatic alternative to because it's.
There's a real English word which is
still used in some dialects of northern
England and I believe also in Scotland
and of course when I speak of that man
who very and I'm referring to a name
known show player I've seen on the or a
name known show player I've seen on the
Farsi year.
Here's the original phrase in standard
English,
a famous actor I've seen on the
television name known as a newly a
shaping word that comes from name and
known markedly and show player is
another melding of two extending words
and Farsi or is a likeness of the German
word found in everyday talk.
We deal with a lot of dramatic words,
but for some under warps,
like which ship we deal with,
many more outland words.
In 1989,
author Paul Anderson for later well
known ritz named unclip dish beholding,
which means atomic theory in thoroughly
dramatic English without any outland
words.
Let's take a look at some of that risk.
For most of its being mankind did not
know what things are made of,
but could only guess with the growth of
world can we began to learn and today we
have a beholding of stuff and work that
watching bears out both in the workstead
and in daily life being is used instead
of existence.
World Ken means physics.
Beholding means theory.
Stuff I believe means matter.
Work,
I think means energy and workstead means
workplace,
the underlying kinds of stuff,
or the first stuff's which linked
together in sundry ways to give rise to
the rest.
Formerly we knew of 92 for stuffs from
water stuff,
the lightest embarrassed to email stuff.
The heaviest first stuffs are elements.
Sundry means various.
This is a regular English word.
It's just less common than various water
stuff means hydrogen.
Barest means simplest and emir stuff
means uranium in my wind.
This seems like English but somewhat
weird.
English.
English is interesting because by trying
to read it or use it,
we get a sense of just how much we
normally rely on nondramatic vocabulary
when we speak English.
On the other hand,
you learn that it is possible to speak
English without any nondramatic words.
If you're willing to use some archaic
vocabulary or new vocabulary based on
Germanic roots.
The grammar is the same,
so it's mainly a matter of consciously
substituting different vocabulary.
So the question of the day,
what do you think of linguistic purism
like English.
Do you think there's any reason to
remove foreign influences from a
language or do you see those foreign
influences as just part of the languages
development?
Let us know in the comments down below.
You can find out more about English as
English dot Wiki,
[inaudible] dot com.
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and Instagram,
and I'd like to say thank you to all of
my patrion supporters,
especially these ones right here for
their monthly pledges.
Thank you for watching and have a
lovely.